we mentioned deshaun watson and we need
to
pivot now to the latest developments in
this
ever-growing list of lawsuits filed
against him
by women who claim misconduct within the
confines of
massages and the numbers are getting
larger
and larger up to 12. tony busby had a
press conference today he's got 10 more
10 more on top of the 12 who are
potentially going to be filing suit
let's listen to some of the highlights
from busby's press conference today
and then we will analyze what he had to
say on the other side
we are now representing 12 women
and we will file the remaining cases the
additional five cases
in due course as we do our due diligence
you should also know that we've also
spoken
to more than 10 additional women
so more than more than 22 women that
we've spoken to
who have reported conduct similar to
that
laid out in our public filings you
should know that at least
one of these women was referred
to deshaun watson by the texans
organization
uh as late or as recent as last week
the quarterback coach quincy avery
referred
deshaun watson to one of my clients
the case ain't about money and it's
certainly not i'm not about seeking
publicity or fame i personally don't
need it
and these women don't want it
this case is about female empowerment
taking the power back and i need to
dispel
some silly rumors yes i
live on river oaks boulevard and i live
near
the mcnair family i don't know the
mcnair family i
i wouldn't recognize cal or whatever his
name is
if i saw him on the street this case has
nothing to do with the texans
has nothing to do with free agency the
timing i don't know anything about that
silliness and i
don't frankly don't care about it texans
are not a team that i follow
this case is instead about women brave
women brave women who are willing to
step forward knowing that they will be
criticized and ostracized
and we should all get behind them
applaud them for their bravery
and support
so at least 22 individuals
who have contacted tony busby and busby
has been
very aggressive in soliciting these
types of cases
it's been a long time since i practiced
law there are certain lines that you're
not supposed to cross
when it comes to solicitation of clients
there are certain things you're not
supposed to do there are plenty of
lawyers who nevertheless do those things
i assume since he did it so publicly
he's within the confines of whatever the
texas bar association allows shireen but
i i i i i feel like it's got to the
point
where he has become so identified with
this
that for some of these individuals they
may be better off with other lawyers
it may be time for someone else to get
involved and
handle these cases because busby i think
is becoming such a major driving force
in this such a major personality in this
when he says it's not about money it's
not about famer publicity while he's
doing a press conference
let me call a press conference for
publicity
so i can say this isn't about publicity
are you kidding me
if it's not about publicity quit putting
things on social media
and don't call a press conference so
look i made this point earlier today
when it was only
seven with each additional individual
it becomes harder to believe that it's
all one big accident that it's all one
big embellishment that it's all one big
fabrication
the numbers eventually overwhelm any
alternative explanation
then there is predatory behavior that is
happening
but you undermine your clients
when your lawyer is acting like a
carnival barker
and he can deny it all he wants shireen
but tony busby is acting like a carnival
barker
and that could hurt the efforts of his
clients to get the justice they deserve
yeah no question mike and completely
agree with it i just said that
the same thing earlier just the numbers
adding up
i mean we've seen some of these cases
with other people
in other places in other fields and and
the numbers
just get to a point where you're going
all of these women
can't be lying we don't know exactly
what happened but
you know we'll see how this plays out i
did note in the press conference he
talked about the houston police
department
is now investigating this looking at
criminal charges if
if the investigation leads that way
that's one thing mike
and and the other is you know deshaun
watson has retained rusty hardin who
hasn't said a lot but
he's one of the biggest most well-known
lawyers in houston and perhaps in the
country you know he's defended people
like roger clemens and warren moon and
adrian peterson so
he knows how these things work but agree
with you if there's more women out there
they may look a different direction and
go to a different lawyer and
and uh and handle it that way as opposed
to tony busby who obviously has sought
publicity out of this i mean he's talked
he's held press conferences he's done
all of that stuff
these these lawsuits all
say that they are seeking minimum
jurisdictional amounts well
it's written in a way to create the
impression that it's not about money but
then when you get to the last page of
the lawsuit
you see the stack of items of
compensation and punitive damages
that are being sought so don't fall for
the idea
that it's not about money and that's
okay it's allowed to be about money
that's how certain grievances are
addressed that's how
justice is meted out that's the whole
purpose of the civil justice system
someone does something to you that is
wrong and you get
compensation for it for your financial
losses for the injury to your
your overall mental well-being there's a
value that's placed on that just like
pain and suffering if you're in a car
accident
you get compensated for your hospital
bills for your pain and suffering
that's how it works that's the system so
don't act like
the system isn't what it is tony busby
if you look through his instagram page
that big house and that swimming pool
and that bentley at the airport
those are all paid for by the money that
he's earned on behalf of his clients
and there's nothing wrong with it it's
the american way there are plenty of
lawyers out there who have made good
livings for themselves
handling cases like this just don't give
me that bs it's not about the money
of course it's about the money because
that's how you level the playing field
between the powerful and the powerless
you just don't give them a stern talking
to
you make them pay that is what teaches
them a lesson
and teaches everyone else out there
there's a societal benefit to this
that you can't get away with this if
deshaun watson is guilty
and the message to anyone else out there
who's either doing this stuff
thinking about doing it thinking they've
gotten away with it
the message is there are people out
there who will hold you accountable so
i'm i'm conflicted as it relates to tony
busby because he is serving
a valuable purpose the civil justice
system is there to give the people who
don't have
power the opportunity to to speak the
ultimate truth
to power and that truth is you will be
forking over some of your money
for what you did to me so i support that
i used to do that for a living but i
don't respect the way he's doing it
that's the the needle i'm trying to
thread here shireen
yeah and and mike you pointed out this
yesterday too
and i think it's an important part of
this is deshaun watson put him in these
himself in these situations so
a lesson to other athletes if you put
yourself in this situation have somebody
with you have your wife there have your
girlfriend there
videotape it whatever but have some
evidence that nothing happened while you
were getting this massage
that anyone could come back and say
something did happen
cover yourself in all situations mike
and i think that's an important part
that other players other athletes can
take out of this
see on one hand and this is another area
where i'm conflicted and i'm trying to
respect the rights of the individuals we
don't know their names and we may never
know their names until these cases go to
trial because they're all
exercising their right to file under the
jane doe pseudonym you balance their
rights against desean's white rights
he's got rights too
but you know from his perspective
the easy response is the massage is an
inherently intimate act and there are
certain things that could happen during
the confines of the massage that just
happened that doesn't mean it's assault
okay fine that's fine you have you have
the right to try to prove that
but when i look at you take a step back
it's like this this is the
if you're a predator this is the perfect
environment
to try to be a predator and have the
ability to say
i'm just a massage i i i wasn't doing
anything
it's just a massage i'm sorry if you're
uncomfortable it's just a massage
so this this is this is a tough one
but the problem is with each additional
person with each additional lawsuit
the it was an accident it was a
misunderstanding
it wasn't assault it wasn't deliberate
it wasn't predatory
it becomes harder and harder to sell
that
that's the problem shireen that desean
watson has
and and doesn't it make it harder mike
for these to
go away to to pay these off i mean if
there's
22 23 of these are you gonna pay off 22
23 people you're going to settle with
them that's an awful lot of money to pay
these people mike
here's what i think happened i don't
know this but what i think happened was
the initial person
approached tony busby busby approached
deshaun watson's agent or
if they had rusty harden involved
whoever and they had these
pre-lawsuit negotiations desean watson
acknowledged that himself
in the tweet that surfaced on tuesday
night that's how i first even became
aware of it before i even saw the first
lawsuit
desean self-publicized the incident and
talked about efforts to settle the case
and he wasn't going to pay a six-figure
settlement and the lawyer says it's not
about money
well i mean desean you and your agent
and lawyer should know that that's
baloney and it is about money
but when when you say my guess is
somebody pissed off tony busby and
that's when he threw the door open
to solicit more clients and it just so
happened
it was an avalanche and all these people
reaching out
and here we go we've got 22 now
so i i look if deshawn is guilty of this
behavior he deserves everything that
comes along with it
if he's not guilty of it
you know this this is a stupidity tax
for putting yourself in the position but
it's going to be harder and harder for
the court of public opinion two courts
of law
well two courts court of law for the
public opinion it's going to be harder
and harder for the people in the court
of public opinion
to think that this is all one big
accident or misunderstanding and uh it's
just amazing
how quickly someone's reputation
can be forever changed
especially when three days ago
if we were making a list of the last
people
in the nfl that we thought would be
accused of something like this
if there was a list of five people that
we would have made three days ago i
guarantee you one of the names on that
list would have been to sean watson
at least for me yeah i think he probably
yeah i think he probably would have been
one of the five for me no question about
it mike and
you wouldn't have ever identified him
with something like this but
yet here we are and you know teams are
going to have to take a step back now if
the
texans are really truly interested in
trading him
they're going to want to know more about
this before there's any kind of trade
talks before you're giving up that much
compensation for somebody you want to
know how this thing's going to play out
and it's entirely possible it's entirely
possible
that deshaun watson did things he
shouldn't have done
and will face justice eventually for it
and
tony busby is carnival barker
snake oil salesman that just happened to
be in this case selling something that
isn't snake oil
that he got he got he kind of got lucky
and fell into
meritorious cases and i'm not saying he
handles frivolous cases i'm just saying
the way he's conducting this troubles me
but it's entirely possible all 22
of his clients are telling the complete
and total truth
and ultimately will prevail in
litigation against deshaun watson
the thing that bugs me the most about
busby because i look
when you practice law you're trained to
constantly spot
behaviors comments facial expressions
anything that would make you think
something is amiss
and when this issue comes up
of potential collusion with the texans
and tony busby based upon the clip we
played it looked like he
raised it himself he wasn't asked that
question he raised it himself silly
rumors
yes i live near the mcnairs when he says
i don't know
how or how or whatever his name is
that does not pass through my bs
detector
everyone in houston knows who cal mcnair
is
when you try to downplay it by saying
cal or hal
or whatever his name is that tells me
you're trying to hide something
that tells me that there is a connection
and that that this is just my opinion
based upon what he said but sharing
didn't that strike you as odd for him to
say cal
or hal or whatever his name is is there
any doubt that his name is cal mcnair if
you live in houston
everyone in he grew up down there
everyone in houston knows who tony busby
is
everyone in houston knows who cal mcnair
is everyone in houston knows who rusty
harden is
they know the principal players in this
i guarantee you
tony busby knows cal mcnair they run in
the same circles they live in the same
neighborhood there is no question they
know each other so yes
that does not pass the test for me and
this idea that he doesn't follow the
team
i don't know what team he's a fan of but
he has on his instagram feed january of
this year it's been seven years
since he posted a billboard to get his
friend and neighbor mr mcnair presumably
bob mcnair
to draft who shireen who did he want him
to draft
denzel johnny manziel he went to a
m just like johnny did yeah so you can't
say you don't follow the texans when you
just hyped two months ago a billboard
you purchased seven years ago
to get the local football team to draft
johnny manziel so
again it this is difficult but these
things aren't mutually excuse
exclusive it's possible that tony busby
is not telling us the whole truth and
nothing but the truth about his
motivations
and what he knows and whether or not
there may be some collusion there
and let me tell you if i'm the nfl i'm
very curious after hearing tony busby
today to wonder whether or not this fuse
was lit in some way
by the texans i'd want to explore that
if i was the league
but it's still entirely possible that
desean watson
is guilty of 22 instances of assault so
a difficult situation for everyone
involved
and as we cover the nfl when these
stories come up we don't go looking for
them they come our way and it's not
within our our purview to ignore them we
have to flesh them out and we have to
inform people we have to analyze them
and obviously this is something we'll be
following
for weeks months maybe years to come
depending upon how long it takes
the legal system to process these cases
and also the nfl now
actively investigating these cases and
at a certain point and the nfl's
personal conduct policy in my mind
shireen is driven by pr
at a certain point this becomes so
significant
that you're going to see the league
put deshaun watson on the commissioner
exempt list so whoever has him on the
roster
is going to end up paying him to not
play i have a feeling that's where it's
going to end up at some point
before football season begins it's all
about pr for the league mike and they do
these things on a pr basis
you know and we've seen the stories
right there's how many of i don't know
how many you've written mike but there
have been a bunch of stories of the last
two or three days on this and they keep
coming
one after another so that's not
a good look for the nfl so yeah at some
point they addressed this from a
pr standpoint hi i'm mike tarico and
thanks for watching
make sure to hit subscribe for the
latest news and highlights
from nbc sports